[Music]
you ready you certain no this is what I
need you to focus here this woman needs
containing yeah borrows it no there are
no Wang Zi how do you think it's going
that looks like it hurt
hopefully you'll have beginner's luck
getting it into purse well intense for
the kids
sure plus potassium chlorate it's what's
very complex
[Music]
[Music]
rated pg-13
[Applause]
[Music]
Jim just gonna say it
I gotta let you go you were just fired
oz let go for liability reasons
involving insurance but one arm the box
and you're so no respect Charlotte Motor
Speedway
I'm having the money
[Music]
and only God knows anything about
blowing up real bank vaults is Joe banks
[Music]
in car sir
ray and yeah we got the plan to get you
out coca-cola 600 is the biggest race of
the year we need a computer with us I
know everything there is to know about
computers okay all the Twitter's I know
welcome to the coca-cola 600
how many more so I use the ball twenty
yards I don't think thirty is it 20 or
is it thirty we aren't dealing with
science here they're gonna know what we
want them to know my life of crime is
over
[Music]
that is massively stupid
it's been handled
oh this is gonna be good that looks like
it hurts
[Music]
don't want everything under me Logan get
naked no big
I said no bacon
[Music]
you moment must be a simple man in his
people saying people say that what you
give in my arm please
[Music]